a vast G babies it's me Kevin Smith
Jason have you ever wanted to get lost
on the high seas with Jay and Silent Bob
well now you're gonna have your chance
go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and some Bob's Cruise Askew what are
you waiting for man get lost at sea with
Jay and Silent bow let's do it
all right's coming villainy Make some
noise
please welcome in Kevin Smith and Mark
Bernardin for fat man beyond episode
number 400.
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith
[Applause]
kids it has been uh JC just told us it
has been over a year since we've done
this April of 2022 was the last time we
did Fat Man Beyond in this space and I
figured I better put on the brightest
Jersey I possibly could
so I could be [__] seen over a year
what have we been doing uh uh I've been
on strike
that's right are you allowed to come up
with anything original here basically
you just have to repeat [__] from other
shows this could be Greatest Hits
um it has been a [__] goddamn minute
how's everybody doing night
[Applause]
of deep apologies I was just sleeping up
until about seven minutes ago
so I'm still getting my bearings under
man [__] I forgot that people put [__]
on the bar and whatnot
I was like look at this I was like clean
up
um
so [__] lovely to be here kids uh
this uh for those who are just tuning in
at home or for anyone who's sitting in
the audience without knowing it is
episode give or take 400 of fat man
beyond
you ever done anything 400 times
woke up
masturbate not in a row
I have it chase this is pretty amazing
kids thanks for coming out you sold us
out the place is [__] packed and I'm
sure we got a [__] show to do do we
have a show to do we got a show to do we
got info and you're like we got some
news anybody in the room see the flash
yet
nobody did you [__] Deacon did
[__] Deacon Deacon went to to uh not
show us what is it called Cinema con and
he saw it uh and so did my boy Ernie
back home my smart Castle uh partner and
all I hear are religious amazing things
uh I in the in my absence of course one
of the things I did was I went crazy and
I went to a [__] mental health
facility and [__] and the only thing
that's keeping me alive is [__]
Michael Keaton Batman
that's what I've been waiting for drinks
yeah I'm a little you brought your own
[__] drinks I did I came prepared and
[__] I was like I'm going to a bar it's
weird for me to bring drinks to a bar
good point like I said I went [__]
crazy Mark don't trigger me
um me and Mark struck this week Mark's
been striking for like two weeks or
whatever the [__] three three is that
right
uh and it looked so fun I was like can I
go strike too and uh he brought me out
we went on a strike date this week it
was adorable it was kind of sweet the
the really cool thing is like you see
people and you meet a lot of [__]
people uh walking back and forth at one
point mark is sitting there saying hi to
some cats
tall guy and a short guy and [__] and he
goes oh this is uh Drew and Brian I was
like what's up and then they were
talking amongst themselves and [__] then
when we left and we crossed the street
we went to different paths I was like
who is that and Mark was like oh that's
Drew Goddard and and Brian Cave on I was
like what the [__] man
well you should have said their last
names and [__] and then we passed them
again so I got to be like he didn't
[__] say your last names I'm a huge
[__] thing and Brian was convinced
that you hated him yeah Brian came on
was like I was pretty sure you hated me
and I was like no no just how talented
you is you just like
skipped across the street you were like
[__] waiting for this light I'm gone I
was like oh my East Coast in me came out
while we were doing the strike because
it but we were in front of universal and
part of the block was like shut down so
you couldn't just go up and down in
front of the gates you had to one point
cross the street go over and then cross
the street again to get to the last two
gates and every [__] writer man like
dutifully waiting for the light to
change and [__] as if they all didn't
come from the East Coast or something
like that and I just started Crossing
against the light and there was a
crossing guard at one point he was like
Hey and I was like [__] strike
I got a son
uh but I did I motored across the street
and uh I didn't get to say hi but then
we ran into him again and that was fun
like meeting people and [__] saying
hi a lot of people uh who are like baby
writers not even baby writers writers
writers who were just like holy [__] you
did a thing that made me want to do a
thing and that was very sweet a lot of
people were like I saw you went crazy me
too and I was like right on it was it
was pretty [__] sweet it was I'm
ready to strike again
you tell me when let's do it man
Wednesday he wins good for Wednesday I
can do Wednesday anybody here striking
are you alive anybody anybody can show
up can you go even if you're not in the
WG absolutely it is all you got to do is
show up every Studio has a there's a
little blue canopy where people are
signing folks in you know I I've been
spending most of my time in the valley
Universal and Warner Brothers and Disney
and CBS Radford tiny little lot right
there in Studio City anybody can come
anybody can walk
you don't got a no license why The
Valleys hottest [__] place on Earth
well it's not that hot yet right and
it's close to my house
um when it gets I want to strike
conveniently yeah I mean I'll wait until
it's like 110 degrees in the valley
before I go to Amazon where it's like oh
you guys have the good weather here nice
what are we striking for tell the kids
at home man who don't understand uh or
the adults here in the room who are also
confused like myself uh the WJ writers
go live America
um has a contract every three years with
the amptp the association of motion
picture and television production
companies or producers whatever the last
P stands for and it's not poop
um and so every three years we we sit
down we have negotiations where the
writer's Guild uh says Hey we'd like a
little bit more because we make all of
the things that you sell and the amptp
says but what if you didn't get more and
those conversations go on for a couple
of months and then they come to a head
and that head can either be resolved by
all right [__] it we'll give you with a
little Amiga that you're asking for or
we're gonna go on strike the last time
we were on strike was 2007 lasted about
100 days where we were trying to make
them give us something to do with
streaming where they're like hey
streaming which is good it's just for
commercials it's just for advertising
like we're never going to sell shows on
streaming We're not gonna like make
content for streaming that would be
ridiculous we were like you probably
will because you're evil and uh and they
did and so now we're striking for for
residuals it's a lot of it is now that
you have streaming and you've decided to
just funnel content into people's homes
and never selling it again when TV was
TV as we all remember there were
commercials those commercials were money
that the corporations brought in and
they had to cut us into that money
because again they're selling based on
our work they had reruns and so every
time they rerun something you get
another little check saying hey awesome
this was your work here's a little bit
of a taste when you could sell it as
DVDs or VHS or LaserDisc I don't know
how many people are old out there but
um when they could keep selling stuff
they could keep paying the people who
made this stuff but streaming there are
no ads for the most part they can
there's no reruns because if you're
running indefinitely so all of that
money that they used to have to share
with us they now don't share with us
anymore
um we're also fighting to try to play
some controls on AI
because AI will I mean we've all seen
movies right you know how that works
Spielberg picture right yeah no not the
that's the Roses why are we so angry at
that movie so many years later
I thought it was cute what's your
problem with it I know I'm sorry that
boy was adorable
um but it's it's you know we're looking
at creative Skynet basically where
AI
algorithms you can replicate and
duplicate and sort of slight variations
on existing work on both the art front
and the actor front and the writing
front I mean there are kids I mean my
kids in college and trying to get him to
not use chat gbt to write his papers is
a bit of a struggle because why wouldn't
he it's easy and he'll probably get a
decent grade you know so why wouldn't
these Studios use an algorithm like chat
gbt or whatever the next iteration of
that is to like I don't know let's write
a season of a show like Murder She Wrote
let's write a season of a show like NYPD
Blue let's write her just a procedural
like we've got hundreds of thousands of
hours of it just ingest it all
synthesize it and duplicate it and we'll
hire one sad person to kind of put new
character names on it make it feel a
little bit less robotic
that's going to happen unless we take a
stand actors are now suddenly beginning
to realize like oh [__] like so there
could be no more extras because we can
just unleash a wave Of Orcs in a box
like [__] Peter Jackson did 20 years
ago with Lord of the Rings but now at
far less expense and it'll actually look
better he's the villain let's get Peter
Jackson yeah [__] that guy
um and so it's it's touching almost
every part of this business and the
corporations the studios don't want to
sort of they don't want to put any
limits on it yet because they don't know
how badly they can exploit us with it so
they're just like hey what if we got
together once a year and just had like
meetings about it I was like hey is it
shitty yet no great see you next year
Meanwhile we're all trying to [__]
Scramble for What Little work we can get
left so it's been posed as an
existential fight for the future of our
business and for the future of the
people who make our business and so I
believe in it I'm out there I'm you know
I'm not out there every day anymore
because I'm an old-ass man but I'm out
there as much as my knees will let me
um and I'm walking a picket line I'm
holding my sign I'm walking back and
forth in front of gates trying to stop
trucks from driving in trying to make
people aware of what we're looking for
um The Screen Actors Guild has just for
the first time almost ever held a strike
authorization vote uh in advance of
their negotiations which means that if
they get that if that vote is high when
the writers have the strike
authorization vote it was 98 of the
writer's Guild was like yes you can
strike we believe in the reasons we're
striking you can go into negotiations
with this vote which says this is how
much of the leadership and the
membership is willing to go on strike to
get what we want actors have never done
this before they go into the
negotiations they get what they can get
they think about it on the other end and
they don't ever do it now they ask for
that vote which means they're taking it
seriously because this is coming for
them too so the actors start negotiating
their contract expires on June 30th the
Director's Guild is also in the same
boat every every Guild's contracts
expires every three years
and there's a lot of solidarity there's
a lot of good feelings out there there's
a lot of momentum and if we can keep it
up if we can hold it up if and you know
we'll have a Bluetooth ad later to talk
about keeping up and holding it up
um
but maybe we can actually make some
difference we can make a change we can
we can pay people for their work we can
make sure that writing for television is
a career you can have and sustain
yourself that directing and acting are
are noble Pursuits that can actually
give you some money back there's always
going to be the upper class the top one
percent that's going to be fine
we're striking for the people on the
bottom who are just starting this this
journey who want this to be workable who
want this to be livable and so
that's what it is that's why I'm out
that's why [__] Kevin is coming with
me every other day
and walking yeah man
and yes anybody can walk anybody can
bring a sign anybody can can just show
some love even if it's as little as
Hawking a horn if it's as great as
[__] standing shoulder to shoulder
with the people who you love and hey you
want to meet some TV writers and actors
[__] come and hang out like I met
Brett Goldstein on the line [__] Roy
yeah he's everywhere he's here he's
there he's every [__] word because
he's at first and foremost that dude's a
writer yeah he's got that other he's got
not just that show but the other show
right shrinking he does that as well
it's a nice dude I was on his podcast
years ago in England when we were
promoting Jay and Silent Bob reboot and
it's a really fun podcast and that was
before
um uh Ted lasso had happened and [__]
and I just I remember liking his podcast
quite a bit as a fun concept and then
years later [__] Ted lasso happened
and I was watching so I [__] I love
that guy who plays Roy Kent and somebody
was like you were on his podcast and I
was like no I wouldn't I went back I was
like holy [__] man I [__] know Roy
Ken
um I realize what's going on there's
something way [__] different
and this is the first time I've ever
done this show not stoned
like that's why I'm like who put all
this [__] on the bar
uh Tuesday it'll be 17 weeks Weed Free
Man uh
[Applause]
don't necessarily applaud that it's life
is so [__] crisp um but I figured I
did the first 15 years of my career at
Weed Free and then the second 15 years
of my career lots and lots of [__]
weed making up for the first 15. now I'm
gonna do the next 15 without but when I
turn 67 [__] all y'all back to the weed
man
that's the [__] time to do it as
you're cresting toward the end and [__]
oh my God right
did you get your drink yet
a bottle of water I didn't get my
wakanda forever but I'll wait on that
because we gotta we got a lot of show to
do is that right second happy to hear
that man hell yeah I'm glad when
somebody's in charge because right now
I'm really not
Charles is in charge of your life of
your days and your legs my nights not
anymore [__] Charles went the other way
uh so what else you been doing this week
since the last I saw you honest on a
picket line honestly I wrote I don't
know if I'm allowed to say that but I
didn't write professionally for a studio
or some says [__] I wrote a comic book I
got my own God so many things have
happened since the last time we've been
here I got my own comic book imprint at
uh Dark Horse Called secret stash press
there's a bunch of them laying around
here
um
and I wrote like one of the honestly one
of the like truly darkest most Twisted
sickest [__] things I've ever written
in my life and I say that as the guy who
made the walrus movie instead and it's
the secret origin of how movie came to
be
oh yeah it's called like the title is
ridiculously long but it's it very
[__] grown up and [__] I went in a
different direction you know if you ever
watched Dogma like uh when they go to
the movie boardroom in that scene uh
Ben's character Bartleby is like movie
the golden calf created by Nancy
goldriff the kindergarten teacher bubble
in 19 whatever that's the only reference
to where the character comes from so I
wrote the entire Nancy goldriff story
and it is it's I'm honestly afraid for
people to read it to be like what's
[__] wrong with you
but it was really [__] satisfying so
I wrote two issues months ago and then
um
uh Ahmed who drew uh Issue four of quick
stops like the Hicks family reunion he's
drawn the book and so I've been seeing
like he finished book one and he's
almost done with book two and I was like
[__] I better get on book three so I
wrote book three and finished that this
week and it was it was a twisted [__]
ride so I did that
um I did Babylon last night how many
people went to Babylon last night
Jesus man yeah [__] oh you kids were
there [__] hey
um it was a it was a good good ass time
uh but other than that we're just
getting ready to uh sell our house the
house that we've lived in for
22 years I guess we came out here it was
going to be 22 years by the time we saw
it we came out here in like 2002 moved
into this house in the Hollywood Hills
raised my kid there uh Jen's parents
lived with us there uh now it's like
Jen's parents moved out Harley's got her
own [__] house so it's just the two
of us in this giant [__] Crypt eight
thousand square foot so it feels
ridiculous to hold on to it so we've
been slowly emptying the house
two-thirds of everything we own are in
storage facilities out in the valley and
It's oddly freeing because all the [__]
that is normally there is gone and you
don't [__] need it like I'm not like
where's my [__] it's [__] packed away
and I don't know it's been kind of
liberating
um but not this week but the prior week
I was down in Florida visiting my mom
spent in the hospital for like eight
weeks but she's on the way out she's
been to three different hospitals and
now she's in one where they like teach
her to walk again because she's been
laid up in bed for like seven of those
eight weeks
um so she's on the mend
um and she's watching hi Mom and um hi
Grace
[Applause]
and then the rest of the time I've been
uh cheating on scum and villainy with a
little place called smart Castle Cinemas
I bought a [__] movie theater in the
time since the last time we did this
show God I've been busy
um I became a exhibitor not just a
filmmaker but but an exhibitor somebody
who like shows other people's movies and
so you know I've always been like real
low-key about the movies like you don't
have to do much to impress me and I'm
not judgy at all and [__] like that
um you know of the two of us you're the
one that's like I demand quality and I'm
like I demand the image moves and that's
about it but as a exhibitor it's all
[__] different now because like you
know I gotta show these movies and you
commit to like weeks at a time to run a
movie and if people aren't coming to see
it you get real judgy real [__] quick
man like where you're like three one
thing I never cared about was the
running time of other people's movies I
keep mine generally short I've do
everything under two hours I think with
the exception of Dogma
um but you know whatever to each their
own but lately man I've been like
[__] you might want to bring that
running time down Jamie and chazelle
what the [__] three hours
um so that's been weird I'll tell you
though my biggest hero in the world used
to be [__] Batman but now it's a
little Italian man called Super Mario
that movie made so much as the highest
grossing film it's modcastle in my
tenure ever I don't know about ever but
since we bought the place man that's the
one that's like done the most business
kids movies are huge for us when we do
events as well like we've done like
screenings of Mall Rats and Chasing Amy
and dogma and stuff like that when I do
my stuff it's pretty packed or sold out
but the generally speaking like film
exhibition man I don't know how other
theaters do it or are doing it but we
had like I've told this story all the
time on opening Friday night of Avatar 2
you know in arguably one of the biggest
movies of last and this year 12 [__]
people showed up
wow Creed 3 was a pretty big movie six
[__] people showed up Shazam
shazidden at all
uh it's tough to get [__] to show up
to the movies and stuff so with Super
Mario you couldn't keep [__] people
away man kids like we had uh we do kids
parties all the time where people like
rent the theater and [__] you could
literally rent smog castle like your own
theater and [__] in it we don't care
I fully encourage people to do that
clean up when you're done but [__] my
God if you've ever won a [__] in a movie
theater smart Castle Cinemas is the
place for you
um interesting angle yeah especially
with pivoting right to kids parties as
well
but um we had this kids party a couple
weeks ago
um it was really rainy as [__] back as
soon as the weekend I was supposed to do
the NASCAR like uh drivers start it was
a little moist in the theater this is
[__] super moist it was so moist that
it was pouring through the [__]
ceiling wow in the hallway outside
screen four so more about how moist it
was oh it was wet it was so wet you
could [__] right now it was so wet that
I had to [__] pick up a mop and start
mopping iron mopped since [__] quick
stop and I was mopping this place up and
[__] like that sucks to be the owner so
I had to go upstairs I got an apartment
upstairs where I live where I'm back
there and stuff so I had to take all my
towels from upstairs and [__] stop up
the water and ship but it was outside of
kids theater where they were doing a
birthday party and they were showing
Super Mario Brothers and my God it was
joyous like it took my mind off the fact
that the theater was [__] pouring
water and [__] to hear these kids
screaming like screaming all through the
third Act of this movie Man just like
she literally cheering the heroes on and
[__] they didn't give a [__] it was a
video game and they were just all over
and [__] and then when that Jack Black
song kicks in they were all singing
along I was like that's [__]
beautiful man and then when all those
kids left what filthy [__] animals
man
they smashed cupcakes into the cloth
seats and [__] like that it was litter
everywhere man [__] the parents were
trying to help me clean up I was like
get the [__] out of here man well they
were looking for the gold stars and
maybe if you just eat nothing no gold
stars for any of those [__] kids
Savages little Savages uh but you know
how to clean up a movie theater man it's
really interesting you get like a
[__] leaf blower and you go to the
back of the theater and you just blow
all the way down and all the [__] goes
to the front and then you [__] sweep
it up I'm learning amazing [__] I do
more cleaning now that I'm a 52 year old
man than I did when I used to work the
convenience store circuit it's pretty
impressive
um but that's what I've been up to men
yeah oh bamf bands here everybody give
it up for JC
the owner of this here [__] facility
man and for those watching at home uh in
case you don't know we're here we are
we've just talked about not having been
here since April uh we are at the scum
and villainy Cantina in Hollywood on
Hollywood Boulevard
we're not too long ago we're still in
the month of May correct it's still May
May the 4th is this place is [__]
Christmas and Black Friday and every and
Mother's Day all rolled into one tell
them how well you did on Black Friday
yeah May the fourth so we open at 10 A.M
we close at two and it was the busiest
day we've ever had so Thursday May 4th
was as busy as an entire week
pre-pandemic whoa that tells the story
right there
[Applause]
um yeah man May the 4th is a [__]
thing here I don't know why because Star
Wars has nothing to do with this bar
uh how you been bamf man good you were
talking about cleaning the theater and
uh I wanted to share two things with
chair just prior to this show we had a
one-year-old birthday party at the bar
the one-year-old rented the bar for a
private first birthday party from 11 A.M
until 4 P.M this afternoon
how sweet man so I mean sweet
how is it legal to have a kids party in
a bar well we're a restaurant
technically oh there you go there's
there's the loophole and then the other
thing is as we're resetting from the
kids birthday party and popping the
balloons and stuff we move all the
tables out of the bar
and we put our hands under the table
it's nothing but come it's all
it's close it's all gum
and I'm wondering
first off it's 2023 who the [__] is
chewing gum all the time yeah no kidding
two you're in a bar there are a million
napkins everywhere and I know you're
over 21 because you're in a bar right
the [__] are you doing putting it under
like why are you like
why are you doing that saving it for
later yeah I'll be back tomorrow saving
it for yeah it's on my hands now listen
to The [__] Problems of the one
percent of the one percent [__] yeah
he's like it's their biggest day the
other day but I had to pick gum off the
bottom of the bar save it Richie Rich
it's interesting though when you own it
where you're like I'm gonna own up
popular bar and I'm going to do plumbing
and electrical work and and clean vomit
because the people I'm paying are
serving drinks so I don't want them to
stop serving the drinks right so you're
the guy who mops up the water or cleans
it is a circle though because you don't
want them to stop serving drinks so
they're serving drinks constantly making
people puke and then you're cleaning up
the vomit and yeah self-fulfilling then
this says for Kevin with love a golden
calf in 2022 Vincent prano
and right off the top I saw this and it
made me think of my little friend for
those of you that don't know my beloved
dachshund shecky
um who uh who has been was with me for
18 years less left this best of all
possible worlds a couple weeks back man
that was
[__] tough if I ever wanted to be
[__] high it was when shecky went
away and [__] that was really uh she was
an absolute light of my life and
honestly something [__] died in me
when that dog went and she took it with
her and stuff so good night everybody no
thank you for this this means the world
uh I miss her all the [__] time man
but I saw my vet
not too long ago and uh because we got
other dogs we got these two German
Shepherds and I took them in to get all
their shots and stuff and uh you know I
was like hey man [__] Chucky right
and he was like Kevin
to get 14 years with a dog is a [__]
blessing to get 18. he's like you can't
[__] complain he's like and all all
of your dogs live insanely long he goes
when I die and come back I want to be
one of your dogs
is that because you won't let them die
and it's [__] true man I've kept them
above ground and I had years to keep
like the other ones alive like remember
I had Mulder and Scully we were big
X-Files fans
um I had Marty I had Louie and I kept
them like I had two three years to get
used to them [__] spiraling down and
winding down Shaggy went in her sleep
never showed a sign of age other than
having like sugar snout and white belly
and stuff like that but was never like
oh I never [__] laying down just
always [__] Plucky as [__] and I
guess because she was so high energy and
[__] when it was time to go she just
[__] went she went in her sleep so I
guess if you gotta go that's the best
way you can [__] go but you know
those other dogs I kept alive for a long
time like they were like hundred pound
[__] dogs so I was really looking
forward to sheky being like [__]
winding down because I was like I'll put
a handle in this [__] just carry
around like a person [__] she was gonna
be easy but she was way easier than I
ever expected so in honor of my beloved
friend who won't be with us anymore men
raise it up for good old deco manchecky
look I am look I am uh should we read a
manscape dance
I mean I can't think of a better segue
from wiener to weiner why not man
[__] makes absolute sense kids
manscaped is one of our sponsors tonight
give it up for the good Folks at
manscapes
uh they always write pretty great copy
man so let's dive in rather than us
winging it we'll say what they want us
to say friends family and loved ones I
bet you haven't purchased the Father's
Day gift yet have you well my dad's dead
so I haven't done that in years
sorry manscape it's going great not to
fear man the leaders in below the waist
grooming are here I'm talking about our
friends at manscape man they're saving
the day yet again with the total package
for the Father Figure in your life this
year it's time to upgrade his game from
waist to face that's pretty good line
right there a little bit rhyming um with
the this exclusive offer have him join
the 8 million men worldwide who trust
manscape and get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code fatman20 at
manscaped.com what are they going to win
mark uh well let's start with the
ultimate Father's Day MVP the
performance package 4.0 inside this
package you'll find their signature
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer brand new weed
whacker 2.0 ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold his goodies
unless we forget about the money maker
manscaped has absolutely changed the
game with their brand new beard edger
Pro kid for fathers around the world
included is their beard hedger trimmer
beard shampoo and shampoo shampoo and
conditioner beard oil beard balm and two
free gifts with their signature beard
comb and scissors we all know dads love
their comfort man and their [__] if
his grooming routine is already dialed
make sure to hook them up with manscapes
boxers 2.0 these are without a doubt the
best boxers for men of all ages man
whether he's mowing the lawn taking out
the trash or golfing in the sun who's
[__] cartoon fathers are these uh
these moisture Wiccan boxer boxers
breathe without breaking a goddamn sweat
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code fatman20 at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code fatman20 man make this
Father's Day one he won't forget with
manscapes we thank the good Folks at
manscape give it up for the good Folks
at manscape
[Applause]
all right all right uh have you uh have
you been to the movies since last we
gathered here I own a [__] movie
theater and [__] I don't go to the
movies anymore now I just see all that
[__] for free
but I'm getting a brand new projector in
my we got five screens it's mod Castle
it's technically I mean it's a multiplex
and the first screen is 230 seats so a
couple months ago I ordered this uh
Barco projector man they're real
high-end laser projectors and uh like
they got one at Lincoln Center and [__]
it's like yeah so I know very fancy it's
the kind of thing you can Market where
you'll be like you know [__]
projected embarco and nine nerds will
come [__] watch it with you and [__]
but uh I that's where I tend to watch
all my [__] I I've seen uh of course
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 I've seen
it twice I saw it once at my theater
where we did a uh whenever a new movie
comes out you can watch with Kev and we
charge you five bucks more and then I
get up and do a q a for a movie I had
nothing to do with
um so I watched it there the first night
Thursday night open and then thanks to
Brett deakin our good friend over there
uh I went to see it in 40x which was a
blessing because I've had this problem
lately of like falling asleep in the
movie theater when I go see a Marvel
movie and then afterwards I'm like man
that movie's missing something it's
missing 45 [__] minutes because I
fell asleep and [__] then I watch it at
home and I'm like oh she has a Quantum
Mania I was like yeah I don't know and
then I watched it at home and I was like
holy [__] this is fun as [__] because I
missed like a good hour of it and [__]
you cannot [__] fall asleep in a 40x
movie because the chair is constantly
moving spitting things in your face and
[__] like that folds up at one point so
you can suck your own dick
um so that was a good ass time watching
Guardians you get emotional in 4dx and
[__] shakes you up when you're all upset
and that movie was pretty damn emotional
but you know
other than spoilers other than like you
know uh some of Rockets friends not a
single death in that movie
we were all thinking like there's gonna
be [__] death Galore Rocket's gonna
die [__] the star-lord's gonna die
everyone's gonna die he kept them all
alive I thought that was I mean showed
great restraints they all survived I
mean they do destroy the spoilers by the
way but it has [__] been out for like
you know three weeks yeah I mean by the
high evolutionary ship had lots of
people working on it oh [__] those
people
that's true and I just read an article
uh where he said that the evolutionary
is not dead he's imprisoned on nowhere
really yeah that's from James [__]
James Gunn man just won't stop tweeting
you know if people are like I heard this
about Superman he's like well I'm James
Gunn and I heard you're wrong you know
any [__] tweets back and then if
anybody asks the [__] thing about the
movie he's like here's all the backstory
that didn't make it he's an informative
[__] but just recently uh I
think this week he put up a tweet where
he's like look he's like I understand
the game now he's like now the game is
people just say [__] just to have me
[__] say it's not true or confirm
[__] and he's like so I I he's like look
there's [__] eight rumors that went
up today alone that were like complete
[__] and I took my time to debunk
and he's like and I can't do that
because I'm storyboarding for Superman
now so he said he's gonna like scale
back a little bit
um I like the movie
Guardians you didn't talk you haven't
talked about it we haven't talked about
it is that right yeah yeah I [__] I
loved it I thought it was beautiful
um you know I was looking for a lot more
death but whatever
um but it was really quite touchy he's
the best of us when it comes to
storytelling I feel James that's why
I've you know [__] Superman in his
hands is going to be a wonderful thing
we had a little exchange last week on uh
Twitter what I put up a tweet uh about
um
what's the dude's name who works at uh
40x Tom the marketing guy at 40x like uh
put together like a Tusk poster but with
the thief's character from guardians and
so I put that up and talked about seeing
it in 40x and stuff and then James was
like oh man I wish I'd been there with
you and then I tweeted well you were
there because you put so much of
yourself in all your flicks it's like
you're sitting there watching it with
James Gunn I was like but do me a favor
or something I forget exactly what I
wrote but you know because I said good
luck with the Superman movie like no
giant spider in the third act and [__]
and then he tweeted uh got it two giant
spiders
um but I I absolutely uh adored it man
watching it with this mod Castle
audience the first night on that
Thursday night was uh absolute Bliss and
I you know I knew I was gonna [__]
love it when it started the way it
started with like baby rocking uh and
and all the little raccoons I was like
oh my God he's gonna rip our [__]
hearts out and I thought that storyline
was incredibly effective uh Lila you
know the otter his otter friend I read
another thing [__] he's a wonderful
source of like not not just the movies
themselves but fan fiction after the
movies because he said that somebody
asked him a question and he said that uh
the the reason rocket would steal
artificial limbs and eyes like oh I'm
gonna get that arm is in memory of
[__] Lila how [__] dope is that
man you could have put that in the movie
made [__] an extra I don't know 100
Grand and [__] but he gave that away for
free on the internet
um you know I thought he'd settled out
nicely everybody got their [__] story
of all story lines were kind of closed
up and and uh you know him
having people go like I'm gonna I'm
Gonna Go My Own Way I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that it was actually pretty
pretty damn touching
um you know wrapping up a Trilogy I
imagine is [__] difficult and stuff
and I thought he wrapped it up really
quite well you imagine
yeah dude
you just did one oh yeah
that's right clerks three now on [__]
DVD
I forget sometimes that I make films as
well
um I mean yeah it is [__] damn
difficult I'm used to rescuing you from
potholes but you're not smoking so
that's true turns out I'm just stupid
um
so yeah he I I thought he stuck the
landing as we say
um you know in terms of bringing it all
home and revisiting those characters I
it was I mean I again it's been out for
a while so if you don't want to hear us
talk about a couple of years but even
seeing a little [__] Michael Rooker
pop up was like oh like he checked all
the [__] boxes man so yeah Doug
what'd you think
um similarly I dug I mean and I dug it
especially because I re-watched one and
two after seeing three like and I hadn't
seen two in years I don't think I've
seen two since the theater death of
yondu is one of my favorite [__]
moments in any Marvel movie yeah really
touching it's really strong but in his
performance when he's like now is really
[__] good but like watching them all
and then seeing them all through the
prism of these are all it's a big rocket
story of which everybody else is kind of
a supporting character and then seeing
how what rocket is and how rocket was
made informs how rocket presents through
one and two like why is he such an
[__] as I think even yandu says like
are you like a professional [__] or
something like and so seeing three and
seeing where he starts and seeing how
what happened to him and thiefs and
floor and and Lila informed this
character who doesn't want to love
anybody lest they fall prey to the same
thing but apparently happens to all of
his friends like that's his history I've
only ever had these four friends and
they [__] died and so I can't let
anybody close to me or they'll die too
and so watching that play out through
those three movies as what begins as a
sort of like because he says that in the
movie too right she's like it's always
been your story yeah that was literally
I just
is that that tracks if you watch it is
really it does I thought that was just
some nice [__] for an otter to say
uh but I didn't I didn't I I don't know
having watched those movies as much as I
have I guess I got to go back and
re-watch one and two now and see if that
tracks is like oh it is Rockets Park and
it was super interesting to see and even
in in Guardians one when you get that
this shot when they're in the [__]
Nova prison and they're putting their
like priors up and like his Insignia
number whatever and his like known
associates one of them is Leela
like even in gardens Lila Lila Lila I'm
not sure but it's the l-y-l-o-a right
and it's like oh it's this I I wonder
how much of this was in place well that
was a character from the comics that I
thought it was but like you know how
much of was he just like all right cool
Lila's here and he's his girlfriend in
the comics but how much did he know that
he would eventually like tell his animal
cruelty story through the prism of
rocket and how much of that stuff would
he refashion and completely retwist for
what what three would be and I also like
I kept I I came out of three as he then
goes to head up DC Comics right DC films
like I don't know if anybody ever read
the comic book we three did you ever
read that book
Grant Morrison uh it's a story about
three animals who were being tested on a
facility who escaped who get uh
incredibly like [__] cybernetically
enhanced and become kind of superheroes
and Friends it is basically the rocket
and Friends story that Grant Morrison
did and Frank quietly in like the late
90s and like they're never making that
movie now because he already did it
Right audience three
I'm saying he was uh inspired by wow
good thing you got that DC job he could
bury that [__] book
um but no I very much dug it because it
got it it landed all the emotional beats
his uh his [__] needle drops are
always like when they're on the money
they're desperately on the money yeah
and did you see the the Florence from
Florence and the Machines little Tick
Tock video no it's so [__] adorable
um where she's sitting in a theater
weeping her eyes out watching Guardians
3 as Dog Days comes up and she's like I
knew they were putting it in the movie
but I didn't know how and she's watching
it for the first time she's like the
superhero obsessed little girl defined
herself in the middle of a movie like
this
it's just so beautiful she said she was
um and she cried at the movie and the
internet didn't [__] crucify her like
they did for me with wakanda forever and
[__] I put up a picture of me crying at
wakanda forever for three days the
internet was like you filthy [__]
[__]
Florence doesn't everybody's like oh
that's adorable yeah let me tell you I
didn't even know that [__] song and
after that movie like I'm playing that
song heavily on repeat and [__] and I
[__] sent it to my kid I was like
this is my jam of the day my kid goes
that was my jam of the day in the early
2000s
she's like how do you not know this song
I was like because I only listen to 80s
music
um that's a great [__] tune great way
to end the flick yeah not
very much Target like James Gunn it's
it's emotionally manipulative but I
don't mind because that's exactly every
movie is emotional that's like if you do
it well I'm here for it like Spielberg
made a living emotionally manipulating
people and it's fine because if you earn
it and if you do it well I'm here for it
and I was here for for all this movie
um you know there's been a lot of talk
about Marvel fatigue and [__] like that
and then with this movie people like
this proves that you can avoid Marvel
fatigue in the right hands but this
movie didn't even feel like it was part
of the Marvel Universe like it didn't
feel like it was part of any of the
phases really kind of stood outside of
the ongoing story yes there was
reference to like Thanos at one point
but there was no reference to like hey
man we gotta [__] get ready for Kang
or anything like that there was no phase
building to it it felt like an island
unto itself I mean the only part of it
that felt a little bit connected to the
rest of it and not in a great way was
Adam Warlock who felt very much tits on
a bullish in this movie where I was like
you kind of have no real reason to be
here other than to show up cause a lot
of Havoc disappear be the dumb character
who eventually becomes a loyal character
like it's very simple and kind of not
awesome like it's the one part of the
movie but it also didn't feel like the
future of Marvel it still felt like the
past of Guardians of the Galaxy it felt
like he's like well I referenced this
guy at the end of two so I better bring
him back for three like I got no
impression like going forward he's going
to be an important [__] character in
the Marvel Universe do you know
something I don't know anything
is that right
thank you
um yeah man it was uh it was absolutely
[__] wonderful
um
but they uh they you know they say that
uh The Flash
right now is tracking to open bigger
than Guardians did
but that that tracks the Guardians is
the third of a thing and the Flash is
the first of the thing kind of with the
third of a Batman thing it's essentially
like Batman colon and the Flash
uh I did also see fast x no [__] has
anybody else seen the fast x yet no
anyone uh I I'm not gonna spoil anything
it just came out how do you [__]
spoil that movie
but they're getting cars and do stupid
[__]
it's a modern day Cannonball Run
I wish it was
um we got a lot of guesses it is
everything that you think fast X is
going to be there are no surprises in
terms of ah so he did impossible [__] in
a car impossibly and should have died 19
times already and didn't
whatever I will say this
um Jason Momoa is having the most
[__] fun and Jason Momo in this movie
is playing the best Joker you've never
seen
he is a hundred percent just like weird
and broken and pansexual and delicious
and like all of it he's he's taking the
best parts of every joke he's ever seen
it's like here's my [__] also now
Hawaiian go
he's great and he's the main bad guy yes
and also uh Reacher is in it Alan ripson
oh [__] yeah see I got him I knew I get
him he's like [__] that movie like
reaches in it really when's that come
back man when's the Reacher's second
season happening I don't know but he
looks good because after the flash
that's the thing I'll be living for man
I love that [__] Reacher series God
it was so [__] good Reacher's just
Batman without the outfit and [__] and
no moral quandary about killing people
shooting them in the back yeah stepping
on their [__] necks and [__] uh I saw
fast decks thanks to the the goodness of
Brett Deacon I saw it in 4dx you went to
a 4dx I did and uh and listen I love 40x
but that movie almost killed me I would
imagine [__] shaking and stirred like
there were a couple times that I thought
I was getting ejected from Cars
holding on for dear life
and the gunshots there'd be some like
piston [__] in my back and so a lot of
gunshots and fast eggs and I'm pretty
sure I lost a vertebrae somewhere in
that theater
um but I still I laughed the entire time
it felt like a roller coaster and I
don't love roller coasters
um but still it was either laugh or cry
and so I chose to laugh I know he's our
friend and stuff and he works there but
I ain't just saying this because of
Deacon like if you haven't seen a movie
in 4dx just go see one of the men I mean
they only pick certain movies not like
you could have seen clerks 3 and 4dx
feel the tears
um they have the water spread they do
um it was uh the it's such a fun [__]
experience and I would imagine a movie
like that it's it's it's a it's a ride
to be sure
um and I've I've I mean we saw [__]
top gun Maverick in 40x that was
wonderful we saw Dune in 40x we did and
that was amazing
um but yeah fast X and 40. contemplate
in 40x
sand
we have 40x tickets to give out when we
do the Q a part we do yeah we got we got
a whole [__] goodie bag so some
people will have a chance to go check
that out
um is it true that the fast x movie is
one of three [__] finale it was
supposed to be fast X1 and fast X2 and
then Vin Diesel was like [__] let's
do a third and so now it's like
apparently a Trilogy is how we're gonna
end this wasn't [__] up at the end of
Guardians when he was like I love you
guys shouldn't he just been like family
it could have crossed over two movies
fire if you're gonna if you're gonna
rank the Guardians movies how do you
rank them
um oh what a good question
I love the death of yondu
uh so I might go two one three and that
doesn't mean three is like not good or
something like that but
one was such a [__] surprise like you
just didn't see it coming when they
announced that movie I was like this is
dumb and then when I saw that movie I
was like this is one of the best movies
ever made but two transcends one you
know by telling that
of kind of Quasi you know father story
with yondu is pretty damn beautiful and
at that point too he you know you're
warm with the family you know everything
about them and so you kind of hit the
ground running in a in a
a flick that
May lack a little bit into the discovery
of one but makes up for a sheer powerful
storytelling you got to remember first
script he's credited with somebody else
Nicole permanent the second one is all
him third is all him so I might go two
one three but I I you know honestly like
I've had a chance to re-watch those
other two so many [__] times so it
could be when three gets to Home Video
the order changes but right now I'd
probably go two one three you
I think I'm one three two
what you put two at the end
wow I'm getting some [__] backup
right there
I love the first one so much because
again to your point it's it was I I went
on the record like I wrote a piece for
The Hollywood Reporter being like this
feels like a bad idea Marvel
and I was wrong the comic book was
[__] terrible like back in the day so
when they announced it I was like you
got Limitless [__] resource you're
gonna do this [__] thing but they you
know I didn't obviously I have no vision
whatsoever that's why there are three
[__] clerks movies
um and I I appreciate the father-son
story more than I did before after
having re-watched two just last night
right but um but there's still some
there's just something about it that
doesn't hit me as hard as it does the
flashback rocket stuff and then how that
then transfers into the present rocket
stuff the the growth of all those
characters manifested in three just hits
me a bit harder than the kind of
irresolution of those characters in two
it's um it's like an embarrassing Bounty
though so there's not one of them that's
like bad they're all [__] wonderful
that's the shittiest one well no not
really they're all really good yeah it's
just like ranking [__] they're all
[__] good man
let me tell you about this girl in
Staten Island
she had too many teeth
the uh YouTube chat wants to know where
you would slot the holiday special into
those
I watched it once uh and you know it's
fun but it didn't you know it didn't
resonate like the movies did so for me I
would probably go two one three and then
holiday special you same it comes in
it's it is a minor entry not that it's
not fun but it's it's fun
how freeing normally when we stream the
show at home I'm up in the chat and it's
nice to not be up in the chat and
what's going on in the chat
um honestly a lot of people are
commenting because we've been we've done
the show virtually for the last year
yeah and I like sit hunched over with a
webcam people are commenting about my
weight and what I'm wearing quite a bit
welcome to Banff man beyond ladies and
gentlemen it's all about JC tonight my
my favorite is Andy Phillips says JC
looks like an extra at that Foot Clan
party
wow
wow Ninja Turtles in 1990
uh deep Cuts man the other was Mitch
Blackmore says Banff man looking like
he's about to go try out for the lead
for 30 seconds from Mars
[Laughter]
Jared Leto a compliment now or not I
don't know I would take it I mean you
have some like leather otter [__] going
on today so this is what's funny is
these are the clothes I wore in 2008 but
I the last time we did a live show I was
like 220 pounds and I'm 170 now oh [__]
so I've lost I
don't apply it yet he's like I was sick
no the wasting disease the actual thing
that
hit me which was wild was uh Jen my
should be wife but didn't never got
married because of covet said uh she
sent me an internet meme and it said
everybody says they die for their kid
but would you be willing to live for
your kid
and I had my daughter when I was 40
years old and then it was like oh like
stop eating like [__] like it was like
wait a second how old are you right now
42. are you serious you don't [__]
look for you too at all
it's because I you look 47.
I look like one of those kids with that
Foot Clan party
so yeah I uh it scared me I it's lived
rent-free in my head every day since of
like every time I want to eat something
crappy I'm just like
I gotta be better I had a boy there's
[__] words to live by right there
[__]
um well [__] for everyone watching at
home me and Mark are irrelevant just put
the camera on [__] Banff man
uh should we do one more ad and then get
to the news do we have to do an ad
already we just did one let's do the
news and then do an ad
or not what do we have to
um I mean it's your show you do whatever
you want yeah again actually it's your
show based on the chat
uh let's do the news and then we'll do
an ad it feels so we're gonna add heavy
to go right away to another Adam so all
right we got news yeah when I yell at
you remember me fondly truly uh Mark
Bernard used to be a newsman before he
was a writer before he stopped being a
writer because he's striking and [__] so
now he's gone back to the [__] news
he collected the news for you so he's
gonna give you the news give it up for
Mark Bernard with the [__] news
[Applause]
one of the last times we were here live
uh JC was like I'm gonna treat myself
and I'm gonna go to that Star Wars star
Cruiser Hotel thing that's right I even
said I would buy you a [__] room man
I was like I'll get you a [__] room
on the cruise yeah the galactic star
Cruiser did you ever go
I didn't uh life got busy hurry up
because they're closing it I I have made
some calls
I heard they [__] got they booked all
their reservations that was the story
that was online yesterday where they
announced that they're shutting down the
galactic star Cruiser because it was
crazy popular and so uh they they booked
every last slot for its final Cruise
really because it's I know they booked
through the end of the year
and then they called everybody from
October through December they'll be like
hey you spent all this money but we're
not going to be here and so they got to
either cancel or roll their dates back
but I'm trying I'm going to try yeah the
final voyage is uh September 28th
through September 30th oh my God so
that's coming up yeah
open for less than or exactly 18 months
90 million dollars was the price tag to
build that [__] thing for those who
don't follow that closely in uh is
Disney World right they built uh this
well I guess we could say it now fake
[__] Star cruise and [__] where we
always could say fake I guess spoilers
um no windows the hotel with no windows
just a bunch of screens that look down
on space and on paper sounded like the
ultimate [__] Star Wars fan
destination but the problem is it
required too much paper to do it at
first it was like six grand for [__]
three nights and then they started
lowering the price because people were
like six grand [__] that it was also
based on double occupancy I believe that
you couldn't get a single room on that
cruise and it's like do you know your
audience Star Wars you could
it was just five thousand dollars right
so if you had two people it's 2500 each
which is but if you're like by yourself
you have this giant room with two beds
you're like but
I'm a nerd guys like I don't know who
you thought I was bringing was it always
two beds like those two pods that they
show in the picture I believe so and I
think you could get like a family room
right that had like four pods there's
yeah there's a the cheapest is like you
can put four people in a room and
there's like two pods and two fold out
bunks
and then there's one that has like a
bedroom with a queen bed and then two
pods and two bunks and then there's like
the Captain's Quarters that nobody can
afford so they don't you don't even know
what's in there
what how many beds were ever featured in
the Star Wars universe come to think of
it like Yoda died in a bed Yoda died in
a bed Luke was laying in a bed in Empire
when he was mending and [__] when you
know [__] Leia made out with him and
[__] Padme was in a bed in episode two
that made sure it wasn't a [__] bed
wasn't she man and then she dies and
then uh the other guy wasn't because he
was like I [__] hate sand it's so
coarse
gets everywhere uh there's a bed in
Andor too it's the first Star Wars sex
in the end there was a bed in Andor yeah
and a bra which there's not supposed to
be space long underwear but I guess
that's kind of a tough sell man sleep in
the bed like Andor
um I heard there were two story lines
like one you could hook up with the
first order and the other you can hook
up with the resistance and they wouldn't
cross over if once you chose a path that
was it so if you were hooked up with the
first order people you didn't get to
break Chewie out which I guess was the
resistance storyline but they included
like deep Cuts mythology stuff in it and
uh stuff that's never been done in the
movies I heard I uh a friend of mine who
went five times in the last year are you
[__] [__] me what billionaire friend
is down yeah really he um he just loves
it and uh
he he hosted he compared it to going to
the Super Bowl as a sports fan that
makes sense where it's like if you go to
the Super Bowl a ticket seven thousand
dollars and it's five hours of
entertainment
you said Galactic star Cruisers like the
Super Bowl for Star Wars fans not every
fan is going to be able to afford it but
it's 20 hours of entertainment for the
same price as a Super Bowl ticket
and for the people who were like well
not everybody can go to a Super Bowl
like you don't see like New York Jets
fans complaining about the prices Super
Bowl it just is what it is he said the
the weekly game that you go to is called
Star Wars Galaxy's Edge and it's the
same price as uh in NFL football ticket
so that's the comparison he made I was
like oh God I guess that makes sense I
wonder I mean some people I guess went
coupled up already but how many people
like hooked up on the galactic star
Cruiser
I I mean you would think outside of scum
and villainy cantina that would be the
best place to meet like a Twilight
do people hook up here I went on Friday
night I went to a wedding of two people
who met here is that right I have I know
15 couples who have met and gotten
married and some of them have kids that
met here at the bar it's kind of special
do you get a taste yeah right Prima
nocta and [__] like that you just got
like 10 of the wedding gifts come to
[__] coming villainy
uh
uh I had a question I remember what the
[__] it was
oh yeah you know how when uh every
Olympics there's always a new story that
says there are 50 000 condoms that get
on the [__] back wall man
never noticed that [__]
there's a lot of ways to watch the show
we're everywhere yeah really you know
every Olympics they have a story that
says that there's like X number of
condoms handed out at the Olympic
Village because after all these athletes
compete they're still there for two
weeks I don't get to go home and they
just start [__] so I want that stat
for the galactic star Cruiser like how
many condoms are just in [__] bowls
running around like hey you know what
they missed out on the condoms would
have to be lightsabers oh [__] oh is it
a red is it a red condom or is it a
[__] green condom I'm a Jedi guardian
purple one ah the rare purple one hear
your father left this for you
your father wanted you to have this when
you were old enough but your uncle
wouldn't allow it
he left it in the care of this old man
in the desert
[__] we should have taken over marketing
that's true we could sell a rumor too
well that's a shame what will happen to
the facility the space uh they don't say
I'm sure it'll just be [__] bulldozed
uh to make room for I don't know Super
Mario Land Maybe
um they got that here don't they that's
in University yeah Nintendo World or is
it Super Mario World timing of that is
incredible yeah it opened March 2022 and
its final voyage is at the end of the
summer
whoops
I don't think they're allowed to say
final voyage man that crosses over too
much with another star franchise
um well pour one out for the thing that
I just assumed would have made all the
money in the world and [__] and would
have gone on forever but
I guess there are only some you know
tough to be nostalgic for something that
won't [__] go away
and uh Star Wars just won't [__] stop
star warsing lately so could be the
people like nah I get enough of this
[__] on Disney plus I don't need to live
it but I like your boy's analogy about
it like hey man if this was a Super Bowl
dot dot dot that kind of makes sense
yeah except the Super Bowl has a
thousand ways for the NFL to make money
and this apparently had zero waves yeah
for Walt Disney to make money because
they wouldn't close it if they were
making money
good point yeah that's true say I love
you my guess my guess is that you can
they're gonna drop it in price they're
gonna get rid of all of the interactive
and turn like the bridge of the cruiser
that you
cosplay and role play into like a
restaurant and it'll be like 250 bucks a
night minus all the interactive actors
they'll just bust down all of the plasma
screens and put in glass like oh you can
see outside now yeah it's not so [__]
up and expensive I mean do it like a
dinner theater though kind of a fair
where you keep the actors and [__] but
you just drop the price down like you
say to like 250 bucks do a show and then
[__] send them back out send them
back it's like medieval times but for
Star Wars oh my God what a good idea
right there and [__] there you go jousts
like raincore jousts in the middle there
sounds pricey
if it goes up for sale I mean maybe we I
know a thing or two about operating an
establishment that might be tangentially
related to the space things tangential
that ig-88 Ted right there that is a
Rolls-Royce combustion tube
Kevin I don't know just to open it up we
got a good thing going a very good thing
uh rumor of the week is that uh James
Gunn has been casting for his Superman
movie
uh and uh he's got some favorites who so
far uh Rachel barajahan from uh
marvelous Mrs maisel seems to be among
the the Final Call List the Lois Lane I
could see that I interviewed her at I Am
IMDb at Sunday on Tuesday absolutely
lovely I could see that that would
totally work
um and apparently he has only one choice
for Lex Luthor
he hasn't said who it is yes he has
Nicholas Holt
that's that's it that's that's
apparently the only I saw rent uh
Renfield you see it yeah [__] fun
movie man really fun flick
um you know you expect Nick Cage to be
as fun as he was and he absolutely
delivered but um I thought he was really
good in a Nicholas hole
um I read some place that Bradley Cooper
maybe no really yeah which I was started
thinking about that going he'd be a
[__] good Lex Luthor too I mean James
Gunn seems to have a Repertory company
of players that he favors and yeah they
took him a task on the internet they
kept going like nepotism and [__] uh
because he has his brother in his movies
and I'm like I don't know if that counts
as nepotism but I say that having cast
my kid in like everything that I've made
since she's been alive
um I I'd cosign Nicholas Holt yeah and
the clock of it all is still a little
isn't that the boy from About a Boy it
is the boyfriend about a boy well he
grew up it's also Knox from uh Mad Max
free Road oh [__] that's right where
he's like
Fury Road and witness me the Beast as
well he's been around for a while man
and he's on the Great
yeah
in which he's pretty great I'm down for
that yeah but yeah Clark is still
elusive they've got a couple names none
of which I'd like recognized David Corin
sweat
anybody
corn sweat love you the guy that ran the
Branch Davidians back in the day
he was on Netflix's Hollywood and was a
lead in Pearl in what Pearl horror movie
what was Netflix's Hollywood they had a
big mini series about like it was like
Babylon but longer huh
so I didn't know that was possible yeah
no they did it
um and apparently you four I guess if
you're gonna he's gonna play Superman
yeah Clark so you want to cast somebody
but not somebody like insanely well
known right
I mean theoretically yeah I suppose
I mean Henry Cavill was an insanely
well-known when he was cast of Superman
Christopher Reeve was an insanely well
known Brandon Routh was an insanely well
known
you know somebody who's acted but not
somebody they're like oh I can only see
him as this other person which is why
I'd want to see the Nicholas Cage
Superman more than oh [__]
tell me about it
um Loki season two the Disney had its
big uh upfront presentation in New York
to dazzle with for advertisers for
Disney plus which I don't understand
what that is but sure I was gonna say
like they don't have commercials so who
are the advertisers I don't know why
they were there
um but they revealed that Loki season
two is gonna drop on October 6th
yeah that's a six
um weekly drop and then Echo is going to
drop on my birthday
November 29th all at once
all at once all at once they've never
done that before first time you get to
binge your Marvel show what is the
theory working theory behind that
um
well I suppose one could say it's a gift
that Marvel is giving us all of us for
Thanksgiving right
or one could say that they don't
anticipate people showing up week after
week after week for that show and so
they're going to just give it to you all
at once so as to not appear
to have a level of attrition they
wouldn't like
um clearly a show that was made before
um Bob auger was like we're going to
stop making a lot of [__] I saw they
announced that quite like HBO max
they're just tearing a lot of [__] off
the channel and
throwing it away or putting it in the
Disney Vault as they in the Disney Vault
yeah Disney is Disney's pulling a lot of
stuff from from both Disney plus and
from Hulu Plus please
I'm fancy Kevin
um what what is it what's the philosophy
there save money and [__] they also woke
up to the fact like we don't want to pay
residuals on this [__] yeah I mean the
residuals aren't like astronomically
high on streaming hence the fight the
wga is having with the the the studios
but it's still not insignificant given
all of the people who are going to need
residuals so shows like Willow are
disappearing from Disney plus relatively
soon I think did you watch Willow uh no
foreign
how many people put your hands together
how many people watched Willow
[Applause]
out of out of like 77 people that was
six yeah
might be part of the problem indeed what
else are they getting rid of thank you
ah
[Applause]
Beyond cooler get your drunk on
um
yeah it's this shit's getting electric
now the chat's gonna be like [__] JC the
real show is watching Mark get drunk
um what else is going away uh let's see
why the last man is disappearing from
Hulu but we just [__] hung out with
Brian cable I know he didn't tell us
anything yeah
um The Mysterious Benedict Society
Disney Plus's Big Shot
um the Mighty Ducks Turner and Hooch
Willow The Mighty Ducks is going away
well the TV show that they made that
didn't work no is that right yes
how many people watch the Mighty Ducks
put your hands together
it's the same four people you guys watch
everything you're like I'm getting my
[__] nine dollars worth
they're being indoctrinated like eyes
propped open
um wow man I would have I would have
thought that would have worked but I
guess not yeah National Geographics the
world according to Jeff Goldblum
oh how many people watched the world
according to Jeff Goldblum oh see that's
the one
still a smattering man how many people
watched [__] one division
that's not going anywhere that that's
gonna stay I think no I don't think
there's anything Marvel that's
disappearing
um
yeah yeah that's about it and they're
basically like yeah we thought they'd be
great we're we but we're not going to
support it on streaming anymore they may
or may not show up eventually on
whatever Disney's version of AD
supported streaming is whether they
license that content out to like Voodoo
or free V on Amazon or whether they
start their own version of that so they
can and technically Hulu always was
where you there's a version of Hulu
where you get ads you know where you
don't pay the premium and then suddenly
like oh there's commercials in this yeah
somehow I have that one because
periodically commercials show up in the
shows that I'm watching on Hulu and it
gets real frustrating and I've tried to
quit and rejoin but I keep getting
[__] commercials man I don't know
what's going wrong
is my first world problem right there
but I get commercials where I don't want
them yeah truly
um so yeah that's [__] happening
which kind of sucks because there were
people who
went into making those TV shows and
movies that had nothing but the best of
intentions and believed as we had all
been led to believe that they would be
around in perpetuity there would always
be a way for an audience to discover
this work
which does not seem to be the case no
during the streaming Wars it just seemed
like everyone's bringing everything
in-house and they're just everything
will live on their respective channels
and we'll always have access to it but
as we've learned in the last six months
man from David zoslav of HBO Max or I'm
sorry Max all the way down to Disney
plus uh that's not going to be the case
they're going to take things away from
us so unless you watch [__] Willow
you're not getting Willow too
which everybody seems fine with
Jesus man
um yeah and that starts
um I think the May 30th I think but next
week ultimately so if you wonder if you
like that [__] you want to watch that
[__] watch that [__] now because who
knows when you're going to get it and
the max turnover from HBO Max did just
when's that happen uh Wednesday I
believe the 20th when they're losing all
their [__] they've already begun to
strip some of that [__]
um
you know like there's a there's a big
ass list of the stuff that that HBO
pulled including Westworld and Nevers F
boy Island sorry everybody
uh legendary The Time Traveler's Wife
the gordita Chronicles Raised by Wolves
and Raised by Wolves is going away yeah
I enjoyed that oh that's the one
we found the more people again now
they've got me mad wait a second uh
[__] Westworld they dropped it was
like a signature show for them
wow what's the idea there it's too
[__] expensive yeah like they I guess
they realized that it would be it would
be worth more if they could sell it to
somebody else then there's to keep it on
the service which has always been there
like they don't get new subscribers by
having that on it
it's such a buzz show for them like when
it started I mean it was the same theory
that led them to to sell Warner Brothers
was producing Batman the cape Crusader
the Bruce Tim animated uh series his
return to Batman
um at Brubaker was running it with him
and JJ Abrams and Matt Reeves were
executive producers it was supposed to
be on HBO Max and then they decided that
it would not be an HBO Max and they
would sell it to the highest bidder and
that ended up being Amazon and the math
for them was it was worth more as the
thing they could sell than it was as a
magnet for new subscribers and so that
was that was the the out the the
arithmetic there for them and I think
that that's down the line what they're
thinking can we sell this for more than
we're getting by keeping it that's what
they used to do before the streaming
Wars began yeah I mean the [__] Bruce
Tim Batman the Animated Series was not
on a Warner Brothers own that was made
by Warner Brothers but it was on Fox
yeah and so we're just going back to
that world where who wants it who's
going to pay for it so streaming
disrupted and now they're just going
back to the way things used to be kind
of yeah David zasloff just had a
statement where he's like hey guys what
if we I don't know crazy idea bundled
these streamers together
that's just cable it's just [__]
cable it's like crazy I know just go
with me is it gonna be like worse than
Gable and more expensive than cable but
it is like cable we should do that
and then yesterday he was the the
commencement speaker at Boston
University I think David zaslow David
zasloff and uh through the entirety of
his commencement speech there was this
chant from the crowd that you said pay
the writers oh really every part of his
speech and you can see him try to muscle
through it and then like there was a
[__] skyrider above and a plane with
a pay the rider's Banner on it
I love writers like
[Applause]
we can be so [__] Petty it's
beautiful one of the [__] most
entertaining free shows you can watch
right now is like what the writers are
writing on their picket signs
um like on my picket sign I wrote and
I'm not saying it's most entertaining
but my but you know they give you a
blank sign you can write whatever you
want and I said without writers
Hollywood is Silent Bob you know very
self-serving one of my favorite things I
ever saw on a [__] board though was
online it was uh this lady was holding
the sign that says a chat was it GPT
chat GPT does not have childhood trauma
meaning you're not going to get a good
[__] show pretty clever
um so yeah that's happening to [__]
everywhere HBO Max is doing it Disney
plus is doing it pulling stuff you
either didn't watch or used to watch in
love uh and and resigning it to The
Ether
um last bit of news little casting thing
which I find interesting um Venom 3 is
happening whether we want it to or not I
mean how could it not then the other one
make like a billion dollars they keep
making a billion dollars or close to it
at any rate and uh they've cast chuatel
ego for the classiest [__] in
the world to come be in venom three
do they say who's playing they don't say
he was playing I'm just like
really it's it's a little bit like when
I first heard that Glenn Close was going
to be in Guardians of the Galaxy
because I didn't know that Guardians of
the Galaxy was going to be any good it's
like Glenn Close is in this [__]
movie
what's happening to Glenn Close is she
okay
he was um well she's not going to be
ignored
um he was in uh Doctor Strange he's in
Doctor Strange so he's been in comic
book movies the only thing that I bump
into is like he's into Marvel projects
it's two different characters
Fair
um Keely from Ted lasso is supposed to
be in venom as well yes do you know
Temple yeah
uh yeah man those Venom movies aren't
going to stop there's going to be a
Venom Trilogy very soon yeah
is that all the News That's all the news
give it up for Mark you gave you the
news
now shall we advertise indeed one more
time kids we got another sponsor on this
here show man that's how popular we are
and it's the good Folks at Blue chew
give it up for Bluetooth
[Applause]
how well does Bluetooth work you get a
month free so you might as well try it
man you're gonna like it and so will
your partner
unless your partner's like I can't stand
directions
for more details and important safety
information and we thank the good Folks
at Bluetooth for sponsoring us uh this
episode folks is sponsored by partly
sponsored by bluetooth Let's Talk About
Sex guys remember the days I'm just
making this up off the top of my head
guys remember the days when you're
always ready to go now you can increase
your performance and get that extra
confidence in bed listen up
bluetooth.com go ahead
foreign
my mind is going through its own mental
Bluetooth it's getting it up for this
Bluetooth is a unique online service it
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Cialis and Levitra but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost
oh I'm sorry we'll go back and forth
yeah uh you can take them anytime day or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity
arises the process is simple sign up at
bleacher.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online kids so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy is that a big problem
waiting in line at the pharmacy I guess
you're like I need to [__]
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package you could be
missing out on the best sex of your life
I have a Bluetooth men everywhere are
excited to see the postman because the
movie with Kevin Costner
because when you pat your packages
arrived your package
has arrived they always say first
impressions are important what about
Lasting Impressions they say there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
Bluetooth can help give you the
confidence where it counts man Bluetooth
wants to help you
have better sex discover your opinion
options at bluechew.com chew it and do
it that's a pretty good [__] slogan
right there and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try blue shoe free
when you use our promo code fat man at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's
pluto.blue2.com promo code Fatman to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details important
safety information and we thank the good
folks I did it I did it at the beginning
I'll do it again how well does Bluetooth
work remember I said that before you get
a month free so you might as well try it
you're gonna like it and so will your
partner do it twice there it is visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring us give
it up for Bluetooth
chew it and do it
uh okay we've done our ads we've done
the news is it time for Q a I believe it
is my friend uh that means we're going
to turn to Banff man himself to pick the
questions uh and my God that means we're
almost at the end of our 400th episode
of [__] fat man beyond you all having
a good time kids
[Applause]
foreign
just chew it and do it
here's a Sharpie if you need one no
these are different oh it's part of the
giveaways you're giving away [__]
adoras I am yeah why because I love
these people because the hard book to
get man uh Mark wrote this book kids a
door in the distance
[Applause]
Dark Horse puts it out Mark was up for
an award at one point right yes Eisner
nominating his eyes are nominated indeed
um wonderful [__] story and so that's
going to be part of the Prize Package
part of the Prize Package there are
three lucky people whose questions get
picked by uh bamf man
um we're we got our the Adora book and
uh Deacon what is in the 40x bag look at
this [__] you want to tell us what's in
there
some Guardian stuff and some fast 10
stuff so oh [__] can I open it can I
show people yeah so God damn it
there's a fast X hat
and it's a snapback my style and [__]
there's two of them
at least in this bag and then um there's
of course
40x tickets how many two
forty X tickets with two corresponding
hats and then what's this
it's a Guardians of the Galaxy t-shirt
[__] hey man you know what nobody's
getting this [__] I'm taking it
thanks for coming on uh so there you go
man get a Guardians t-shirt you get two
40x tickets and two fast X hats thanks
to the good Folks at 40x man where can
they how do they find
how do they find a 40x theater near them
how many are there
are 50 plus in the U.S all in major
cities and [__]
closest one here is where North
Hollywood North Hollywood and there's
one in New York City as well
um you go to 40x.com or something like
that
they're gonna fire you unless you know
the [__] website go online in her 40
X Men and find a theater near you folks
uh but they're going to be people right
here in this room gonna walk away with
it but it means that even if you're not
from the area and [__] and you win you
still be able to go see a 40x picture
someplace else if you're not in Los
Angeles anybody here not from Los
Angeles put your hands together
oh where you guys from
[Applause]
where
Denver Rock and I are in from Colorado
right on man what do you think of our
[__] up City
it's wonderful isn't it
uh where else somebody from someplace
else
where
San Diego the [__] man that's California
the far away land of San Diego
um okay what do you think bam bam what
we got all right we had a lot of good
questions I picked my three favorite
that YouTube is gonna yell at me at but
I closed my computer so I won't see it
do we have any Super Chat people no I
didn't because those [__] pay money
man
I didn't know to be fair these people
also paid money yeah good point good
point but they paid him the [__]
money
uh okay Jonah
first question Jonah Jonah where are you
at Palazzo come on yeah come on give it
up for Jonah he's asking the first
question
all right with the Jay and Silent Bob uh
Crews coming I wanted to know if you
guys could go on a cruise with either a
comic uh cinematic franchise or a TV
franchise who would it be that's a good
question and it also gives me a chance
to plug uh Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise
happens in February of 2024 we're going
to leave Miami go to the Bahamas and
then come on back to Miami three [__]
days and uh it's more entertainment than
you can shake a stick out if you like
[__] Kevin Smith stuff oh my God uh
Jason Mew is going to be there Brian
o'holler and Jeff Anderson uh I don't
know if they announced the other guy but
and I you know I can't say it but
there's another guy who's been in my
movies and
there he is right there
uh Mark Bernardin is going to be there
we'll be doing fat man beyond we'll be
doing Hollywood Babylon we'll be doing
Jay and Son Bob good old we do an
edumacation um it's a real it's a good
time and I honestly thought when uh
Jordan as J Muse's wife she runs our
company and stuff she was like we're
gonna do a cruise I was like this is
where this [__] falls apart man I said I
will probably set sail with less than 50
percent and we're already at like 75
sold out and [__] so join up at Jay and
Silent Bob Cruz's Q if you're into that
sort of thing get lost on the high or in
my case not so high C ladies and
gentlemen uh okay the question is who
would I like to go on a cruise with yeah
either a cinematic comic or a TV
franchise
not the cast of Jaws I'll tell you that
[__] much
um you know it's deep Cuts but like
[__] for safety's sake
you know I'd go with the Mariner from
[__] Water World
he seemed to get [__] done on the high
season what not plus he could breathe
underwater that's one of my favorite
moments in an action movie of all time
when he [__] like shoots a [__]
Spirit somebody hits him right next to
the head and the guy looks symptoms
playing and then Kevin Costner goes yeah
um he's one of my choices uh who else oh
[__] Bobby Drake Iceman
because the [__] [__] goes south like
freeze all this [__] but sharks coming
for you freeze that [__] thing
obviously sharks are a big thing in my
life
[Music]
um
and uh who else is good with the water
oh the [__] Zan and Jaina the Wonder
Twins
because the one [__] all I could
work with was water you
I was tempted to be like The Love Boat
crew like but like it's like whatever
it's another day for them Isaac hey
Julian Julia Cruise director
um and then I started going your route
like I like people who were good on
boats and on the water I'm like oh
[__] Captain Jack Sparrow would be
fun to be on a cruise with oh [__]
except all of his boats sink so like
yeah Less Fun and then I'm like I'm
gonna go on a cruise with like the
Ocean's 11 crew because then we can
Heist the [__] boat that would have
been my pick right and then but they're
also like having a good time while doing
it like they all seem like they're cool
to hang out with they like like good
Deli like I'm a big fan of people who
who dig on the food so I go Ocean's 11.
I go Danny ocean and Company
um and I'll make it I'll I'll get richer
for being on that cruise because we'll
have stolen all of the cruises money
um Yoda just to see him in a bathing
suit
bluetooth.com ladies
green chew
um yeah [__] what do you got bamf man
Gilligan's Island it's a three-hour tour
that lasted for 20 [__] years and
your vacation true man you'll learn how
to make a zillion things out of a
[__] coconut except a boat that will
get you off the [__] Island
uh excellent [__] question man you
win give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen Jonah gets to take home Adora
in the distance of the 40x bag
don't leave me hanging
don't forget what oh is that what that's
for [__] man I signed three and I was
like what greedy [__] bought
three also you get to move away from the
camera Jonah
Jonah's gonna walk away with one of
these amazing [__] prints by The Dark
Knight 400s Nate Gonzalez look at this
our Batman 400 this is an absolute
[__] framer can't you get this put on
a t-shirt as well
where's your website
returns.com it might end up on T public
but T public will probably take it down
within like two days walk is it because
like copyright yeah well I wouldn't
complain an unfeatured prominently and
[__]
and [__]
uh a parody law parity law you they do
have Empire strips back which is Star
Wars burlesque you can't put Kevin and
Mark in hats
that's a parody
do we have to take our clothes off is
that what it is you want to see that go
to Jaden selling Bob's cruise is cute
see me and Mark in bathing suits uh
Jonah you get this as well give it up
for Jonah
thank you
uh okay
yeah roll it up and put it in the back
that's a good idea all right what do we
got bamf man Martin Ponce Martin Martin
Martin
what's up y'all Martin how you open give
it up what do you got Mommy
can you hear me okay we can hear you all
right um so my question was
uh
silent film
no dialogue at all based on any fandom
Marvel DC whatever
um what would it be and why would it be
so entertaining with zero dialogue
um as a man who's made two half silent
movies
called Jay and Silent Bob
um I think I might have to disqualify
myself or at least go second you go
first
all right a silent movie about somebody
okay
I mean part of me really wants to do
like
Jackie Chan [__] because that stuff it
transcends dialogue to such a degree
that that and he's so emotive that you
kind of you always know what's happening
in those movies even if you saw them
without subtitles without a dub
um so like project a 2.5 or whatever
would be [__] great armor of gold too
give me that
um but comic book wise
um
Daredevil
oh [__] you know I think he took away
his sight now you're taking away a sound
as well you
know and I think the the idea oh no [__]
snake eyes
story with Snake Eyes is a silent story
so just we'll do that they already
solved that problem for me okay they've
been snake eyes and Silent Bob
a wordless [__] film and [__]
um you know just to see if you could
pull it off I would like to see Glenn
Gary Glenn Ross done as a silent film
the movie is one of the most dialogue
heavy movies of all time
um I guess
let me see man
what movies have I loved and they're
actually but they don't you know I would
take a [__] Michael Keaton Batman
movie Silent just because I'd take a
Michael Keaton Batman movie any day and
if that's one more variety of it I would
take that but you can get away with a
silent Batman like generally he don't
[__] talk he's not supposed to talk
and if he's chatty he's Reacher so
Reacher
silent [__] Reacher all it does is
break necks and he doesn't even [__]
tell you why
look at everybody who wants to say
something he's just [__] neckbone
I'd like a Buster Keaton Batman
a buster key Batman where buildings fall
around
um Banff man you got one yourself
sequel to CODA
wow that's all signed just [__] break
my heart again yeah really here come the
tears that was like the ugliest cry I've
had in a long time coda coda apparently
you haven't lost an 18 year old
Dachshund my friend
but I'm just talking about a movie man
good point good point
um all right great [__] question give
it up for him ladies and gentlemen you
win
[Applause]
swag
goddamn pleasure all right Banff man
take us there all right last one Daniel
Roberts Daniel come join us Daniel
Oh Danny Boy the pipes the pipes are
calling
hey man hey guys hey man excellent
[__] shirt there excellent shirt
good pun thank you
um my question is
a little bit of a two-parter but first
part is just what are some of your
favorite memories over these past 400
episodes of doing Batman Beyond
Fat Man on Batman
um my personal one is just uh that makes
me laugh the most when you guys do
Disney after dark so you guys we're just
sometimes break into dirty versions of
Beauty and the Beast or Aladdin
um yeah I would love a reprise of any of
those if you would love to do
Disney after dark yeah Disney after Dark
[__] Snow White and the Seven Dwarves
so much sex
that's not gum under the table
um what have been my some of my favorite
memories uh most of my favorite memories
is in regards to the show generally
happened right here in this bar we've
had uh so many wonderful like live shows
back in the day which you know night
after night when we would do it when we
were on a roll and we were doing it like
weekly and stuff
um it was like a happy place for me
coming here and [__] letting go of
life for a little while and the
familiarity of uh [__] people like
that you this you know I I do lots of
live shows and for the last 20 years
that I've lived in Los Angeles I've done
a lot of live shows in town but like
whenever we do Babylon I don't really
see the crowd you know I mean I see a
crowd but I don't see faces but like
coming here for [__] years and seeing
Jamie you know cat ears [__] where
are your cat ears by the way 400th
episode you didn't wear the [__] cat
ears man
go home
um get the ears seeing Nate here show
after show like Nate went from being a
guy who came to the shows to [__]
being the guy who did the artwork does
the artwork for the shows one of the
most integral parts of the [__] show
and it wasn't always the the case like
you know our friendship and our Business
Partnership grew because he came to the
show and because this space allows for
you to make eye contact with people like
there's not a bad seat at scum and
villainy
um doing the show here and watching the
bar grow watching JC's business go from
like
you know when it when he started it was
a pop-up bar that was meant to last for
a couple [__] months and then one day
he was like this could actually be a
business and watching it transition to
that and watching like the [__]
pandemic come in nearly [__] kill it
and watching him survive that and and
Thrive afterwards those are really great
memories standing next to Mark and
having Mark like give out amazing ideas
for [__] free and being like shut the
[__] up
um listening to mark break things down
as a writer you know and I say that as a
supposed writer myself but like
listening to him [__] break things
down and be like oh my God I hadn't
thought of it that way you know the show
I I love Babylon don't get me wrong but
unlike Babylon our chief job there is to
like [__] make you laugh make you
laugh make you laugh this show is
allowed to be quiet from time to time
and and that's something I've always
appreciated about fat man beyond
um we we definitely try to you know
bring a tickle your funny bone but it's
not the first priority like here we get
to nerd out here I get to talk about
things in ways that I don't get to talk
about them anymore in the outside world
you know I've been married for uh we hit
24 years fairly recently and and you
know we watch a lot of [__] uh well I
thank you
she's not watching so [__] she ain't
gonna hear it um but uh you know I she
dutifully during the pandemic started
watching some Marvel [__] with me and
and definitely got into it and whatnot
but and that was fun on its own level
where I could be she'd be like what does
that mean I was like oh pause let me
tell you the whole back story and [__]
but the idea of you know my childhood
was spent talking about
the [__] I love deep Dives and deep Cuts
conversations that would last for a long
time one of my favorite things about my
friendship with Walter Flanagan back in
the day was talking deeply about things
that nobody would ever really
discuss [__] deeply going deep into
Batman lore DC lore Marvel lore and
stuff and so you know I don't get that a
lot in my daily life but in doing this
show
you could really [__] nerd out and
not with the [__] pressing needs are
like well I better say something [__]
funny the whole stretches this show even
tonight where it wasn't about making
people laugh it was about really is that
[__] true and just gossiping you know
[__] doing the news like hearing
about [__] it's a lot of [__] that I
heard about here that like I didn't read
about in other places over the years
um so so much of this show is is a happy
place for me it's always fun to come to
a full house and try to be entertaining
and clearly whatever broken aspect of my
personality the demands that I be in
front of people and [__] be the
center of attention brings me to a live
Forum but like in this live Forum it
hasn't always been about the
codependency of like I'm funny please
[__] love me it's been about having
discussions it's been about talking
about things that I love dearly with
people that love those same things just
as dearly and every once in a while we
can laugh about the similarities of
something or the hilarious aspects of
their nature or something but being
around like-minded individuals in a safe
place you know I mean I don't want to
[__] tempt fate but knock wood like
this place is right on Hollywood
Boulevard and for those who aren't here
it is [__] terrifying on Hollywood
Boulevard anybody could [__] walk in
here and [__] do bad things to us and
nothing bad ever happens here you know
it's we're in a bar and [__] people
could be [__] traditionally when you
go to bars people get drunk and that
leads to hostility and [__] potential
violence never [__] seen that happen
here man a bunch of like-minded
individuals coming and celebrating when
I was a kid I used to go to church I was
a Catholic kid and I was dragged to
[__] Church my whole life and [__]
made a whole last movie about it once
but like this has become My Chosen Faith
this is like going to mass for me it's
funny that we're doing it on a Sunday
because it is very much that we come
together we congregate over something
that we celebrate the celebration of
[__] all things pop all things of the
of the culture that pops so I've got
specific memories and [__] like I'll
never forget Mark giving away that
[__] amazing [__] Sleeping Beauty
story and [__] like where I was like
that is legit [__] wonderful you
could sell that
um some of the jokes that like didn't I
didn't think would [__] land that
popped up that became a thing watching
JC become Banff man like the third
official person on the [__] show and
to the point where you know JC was over
at [__] Star Wars celebration as we
showed the video on one of the shows and
people [__] recognized him from this
show you know not anymore because now he
looks like a dude from the Ninja Turtles
movie but
so everything about this show over the
years and particularly doing it here I
mean don't get me wrong when we stream
it from home that's incredibly
convenient and stuff but like
coming to this place and being around
all of you as really done wonders for me
at a time when I really needed that
um so yeah nothing but [__] golden
memories of doing the show you got to
remember this show started
as like me talking by myself to people
that worked on Batman
you know and and I over the years and
I've never [__] a month goes by
without somebody being like I missed
that version of the show
um and I I like I gotta say I don't like
I love what the show evolved into as
much as it was beautiful when I started
it and because it was feeling some sort
of [__] need for me
I didn't realize how much I needed what
this show would eventually become so I
absolutely love doing fat man beyond and
I love doing it here man
foreign ER
uh well this this actually is not my
400th episode of fat man beyond this is
like I started I think it was like 78
maybe 77 78 something to be like hey
come in let's talk about Batman pick up
your favorite uh your 10 favorite Batman
stories and we'll talk about it that was
that was the memo was that was the brief
um you're like yeah we'll talk about
your 10 favorite Batman stories I feel
like I'm gonna pick my 300th favorite
Batman stories and so I wrote down a
[__] list and then you're like no
wait there's this [__] Peter Weller
um he's doing The Dark Knight return
Dark Knight yeah returns as a two-parter
let's let's just [__] we'll go see
the first one and then we'll do a
commentary track for it and then that
became commentary tracks and that became
like [__] okay let's just do the
utility belt let's let's turn it into a
thing oh my God that was just like this
little [__] segment in the middle of
it where we did like the news and [__]
yeah and all this catch-all let's unpack
the utility belt for this week kids
um but my the the thing that I remember
the most is when the internet discovered
that I was black
[Laughter]
laughs
because
like I know surprise they're keeping it
a secret this whole episode 400 surprise
look what happened you guys
um because for the first chunk of those
things like there were no cameras it was
just an audio podcast it was just me
going to his house and talking about
[__] and sometimes that [__] would be
whatever the nerd [__] of the week or we
saw Batman movie Let's Do A Commentary
track for Batman Returns that'll be
great and then sometimes that [__] was
like let's talk about things like
representation let's talk about things
like
um you know diversity and inclusion and
people didn't know why I gave a [__]
about that stuff until like JC showed up
and was like let's put a couple cameras
in here like it's been a GoPro people
were like Jesus your friend Mark is woke
yeah before it was more than woke
you wait
and uh and and the minute we put up
cameras there was this little baby meme
that went around for like a couple of
weeks that was just like wait Mark's
black
because there is nothing about my name
that betrays my race there is as my
mother would very fondly say when she
put me on the phone with like the power
company and [__] like you don't sound
black unless you want to sound black you
know and so you can be a ambassador of
the family into the white world and get
on the phone and they won't know and you
can just you yeah you can be that person
and so once the cameras you have a
secret identity man I do as the like the
Con Ed con man
um but once the cameras went up and it
became this like little blip of news
within this community they're like oh
[__] okay interesting moving on
and as time passed on the podcast and as
the world began to shift being able to
have a conversation with people who were
already on my side we already had a
bridge together we already had common
ground because we love this stuff and
then the world broke in half
some would say splinted in a thousand
pieces Splinter short film
um yeah
well done the other thing I take from it
um but as the world shifted and changed
being able to speak to an audience with
lived experience as to what it is like
to be this person in this world
aside from the fact that we all share
love for Marvel and DC unless they see
the Marvel but whatever
um and Star Wars and Star Trek and the
nerd world was our world and we got to
have common ground there to then have
conversations that are outside of that
and being able to have them with honesty
and with Clarity and with no misgivings
about intention was just oh [__] I never
thought about it that way is so much of
that conversation that I've had and
being able to interact with his audience
which is vast and deep but
not overwhelmingly Brown
and then being able to sort of explain
to people how I see the world and how
being me has turned me into this person
who can love all of these things but
still be understanding and aware of of
both my role in society the the way
society and prints rolls upon me but
just being able to have honest
conversations and being able to talk to
people and I think that that's what a
podcast ultimately ultimately does is it
shares ideas sometimes we're on board
for those ideas sometimes those are
these challenges but to being able to
have these conversations with people
that I wouldn't be able to have
conversations with I'm I was like the
internet's black friend for a little bit
and then being able to talk to people
about stuff like that has been
incredibly rewarding for me and in some
cases challenging and in some cases
scary because there's always a segment
of the population that doesn't want to
have these conversations that doesn't
want to engage with faith on on topics
that frighten them or or you know scare
them or they disagree with or challenge
their perspectives in the world it's
being able to enter into that part of
this of of this part of my life with a
sense of clarity and with confidence I
mean this podcast taught me how to speak
in front of people
you know it taught me to trust myself
when talking in front of people to be
able to go out in a wire of a story and
know that I'm going to find a place to
land it even though I had no idea where
I was going to start it and I'm a little
lost in the middle of it but I can bring
a story home because
I've done this for 322 times like I've
kind of figured it out but it's that
thing of being able to connect with
people who I ordinarily wouldn't be able
to connect with and more for them to be
able to connect with me and to
understand that like we're not that
different at the end of the day we all
kind of want the same things at the end
of the day even though you might be told
by a dozen different places you don't
and we don't
it's not true let's talk about it you
know when I was on Twitter that was my
favorite part of it was being able to
engage with an audience and have
conversations about ideas and
perspectives and being able to challenge
what they thought and being able to be
challenged by what they thought
um that's been for me the great gift of
this podcast is being able to to
interact with people I never would have
met in a million years and hopefully
James and mines by being a person they
never would have interacted with in a
million years [__] beautiful give it
up for that
oh God
I've never uh
never occurred to me but we're kind of
like the [__] uh White Men Can't Jump
either that or the different strokes and
I'm [__] Mr Drummond and you're
Arnold
power Dynamic I think
prior and [__] yes Gene Wilder and
[__] it's pretty bad yes
I see Batman's got the mic he's got
something to find I got I got some I
remember because you guys were doing the
show at defy yes in Beverly Hills and
Jordan called me and it's like
I think we're gonna get a space and it
was it with grunberg right around the
time you were guys were doing uh because
you were there as well too I didn't do
defy Jordan brought me in after defy
like I took over the show from defy
which is probably
around 150-ish
um and we did it there and then we did
it in your living room and we would me
and Andrew would show up and we'd shoot
like three episodes at a time or
something when they were like half an
hour each because remember the idea yeah
the idea being the internet really only
wants short [__] so we're connected to
the 25 minute episodes and then as we
head into hour three that's a nice
podcast uh but then I'll never forget
the first show we did here it was like
electric and at like 2 30 in the morning
you texted me and you're just like that
was crazy that was so much fun like how
do I get in on this like it was so I'll
never forget that because I was still
awake too I was like oh my God that was
so much fun
because we I don't think we'd ever done
it with an audience either no we we've
done we've done like a lot of filmed
shows at at grunberg's studio and then
at the house but like have you ever been
on the road we did it once in England
yeah we did it at a convention in
England in like 2014 maybe right I think
and then we had started to do like we
went to Detroit we went to Arizona
that's right we did it at the at the
free the festival yeah yeah yeah like so
we did there was a couple years where we
were actually kind of like let's go to
Indianapolis we'll do it let's go to
[__] Canada and do it but we had
never had a home base we never thought
about like selling tickets on a regular
basis we never thought about a residency
the way this oh my God that's right we
have a residency this is like our Vegas
show
I always thought I remember the first
time we came here that that booth and
when I do the show I always think about
that in my head that Booth was where we
were going to be
um but JC was like stand behind the bar
and I was like well that's never gonna
work
[Music]
and that's also an aspect of this show
that I don't share with the other live
shows I've done like whether it be Jay
and Sal and Bob good old or Hollywood
Babylon those are seated shows this show
has always kind of been on its feet like
whenever we're here we're on our feet
doing the show and it makes a difference
there's a different Dynamic to it as
well the um the other thing is the
pandemic shows we did which we have some
really cool guests like Malcolm Barrett
I remember that show and the Matt
shackman show when division came out we
got like
you know it was the hottest two shows
and we had the head guys of those but
also the pandemic shows for me because
like we were
consistent sometimes we do like two
shows in a week and that was like my
hanging out and it's started depending
on what the law was at the time like
we'd either be here with like Plexiglas
remember there was Plexi between me and
Mark for a while like first it was oh
boy yeah we had to be like nine feet
away so we have the table between us yes
and then it was are we gonna be closer
but we got the [__] plexiglass and
the
danger averted ship safe but and when
you have been and always shall be my
friend how do you like my solution too
the
um the cool thing for me though was you
know the
like I found out I was gonna have a kid
on Thursday we shut the bar down on
Sunday
on Thursday I canceled my wedding so it
was a pretty intense time and like
coming in here and doing the shows with
you guys and then doing them from home
and then coming back here and doing them
here and then doing them from home that
was like the only human interaction I
had outside of Jen
um which was really cool and then I also
got like we didn't do baby shower we
didn't have our friends
like none of our friends saw Jen
pregnant
think about that like none of our
friends saw her pregnant we our entire
time was in a vacuum so I got to share
my story with the world every week of
like what it's like to own a small
business during this time and what it's
like to
about to have a baby at this time and
and even after she was born like what
that was like and so this was my outlet
for getting to share like I'm gonna be a
dad that
I didn't get anywhere else so like that
was really really cool
um and I think Jen's pissed because like
she didn't have that outlet at all I'm
gonna go hang out with my friends and
talk about the kid
um she's like I'm gonna raise the kid
[__] you uh and then just hear like Rick
Baker Marcus and mcfeely
uh Mark with Malcolm Barrett behind the
bar was like
I mean like everybody peed their pants
that night
um watch men so black well yeah Zach
stents who was here and um and Grant
Morrison was like one of our first
guests oh my God that's right we had
[__] Grant Morrison live um and he
was talking about like Wonder Woman and
the people who created Wonder Woman were
all
into bondage into bondage and the truth
like it was I just feel like there's
been so much cool stuff that like you
can't even remember at all
that's good I mean that's what life
should be a series of [__] so much
cool [__] that you can't remember at all
it'd be sad if it's like I remember the
10 things that ever happened to me and
that was it but like we've got so much
constant Joy going on with this show so
much Discovery so much fun that like is
tough to nail down
like a bunch of memories it's all I have
no bad memories in regards to the show
whatsoever no trauma in regards to fat
man beyond
um
yeah man it's been wild it's been wild
watching you become a personality like
to go from a writer to like a guy who's
comic timing is on [__] point and
stuff like that and to watch you become
famous you know my my kid is often
talked about whenever I try to drag my
kid into one of my [__] projects she
generally at first is like oh my God
please not another thing and then
relents because she's like you know you
know one day you're gonna die and I'm
like [__] thanks man and she's like
and I don't want to regret saying no
just because some people on the internet
are like oh you always work with your
dad but she's like but she's like I
figured out
your love language is that you pull
people in
to do a thing like I don't hang out with
people like you know it's not like I'll
leave here and I go bowling with [__]
friends and [__] every friend I have I
always bring into a world where I'm like
well why are we having this conversation
without an audience like come [__] do
this and let's do a thing together and
so my love language has always been to
like bring people into the thing that
makes me happiest in life making movies
[__] being in front of people doing a
show so forth and so on so whenever you
see me doing a thing with somebody
that's the highest esteem I have for a
person to be like come and play
um because that's the only place I
really kind of play and uh you and I
have been playing for a long [__]
time it was like finding somebody in
childhood
that knew how to play Star Wars
correctly and you know what I'm saying
and had the opposite figures I know so
we compliment one about one another yeah
man it's it's been a really good [__]
run and it's a shame it's over now no
[Laughter]
man wouldn't it be nice to one day get
to like fat man 1000 or something like
that or all
I mean you'll all have to come to the
nursing home with us
as they wheel us out we drool and we're
like [__] welcome Jeff's kiss
and our teeth fall out
um yeah I mean it's
this show has eclipsed and straddled
just about every major life experience
for me the last 10 years going from
being a journalist to a professional
writer all of the [__] trauma and
drama in between all that and all of it
is because and I I will say it gladly
and proudly is when Kevin asked me to do
a thing I say yes
like everybody's like hey man do you
want to do you want to co-host a podcast
with me like sure Kev hey man do you
mind if we put up cameras sure Kevin hey
man you want to go on the road
absolutely hey man should we go hang out
at this bar and do this once a week yeah
man hey should we do this on Zoom sure
hey you want to be in this movie yeah
hey do you want to write a he-man
episode yes I do how about this next
thing Darren tooten hey Kev can I have
some lines no
[Laughter]
yeah
I never asked I made a career out of
being quiet in movies you could do the
same [__] thing I never asked him
just a little Crest falling when it
doesn't happen and then I also then
realized that well that's also the
highest compliment because that's the
role he would give himself the person
who doesn't say anything so like anybody
can say a line can you sit there
silently and make them love you
and you can I try the only thing I've
never asked is like hey man let's jerk
each other off
that's Batman 500. all right
this episode is you
[Laughter]
wouldn't do it
that's a free ad Bluetooth
um yeah man there's a lot of love in
this room and and uh it's you know not
just between me and him and us and him
uh it's with us and the audience and
it's with us and and people at home but
the audience here in this room a lot of
witches repeat cats regulars if you will
makes it feel like a living breathing
version of cheers to some degree man and
that always looked fun when you watched
that show it's like oh man [__]
that'd be a cool thing I I'm not a
drinker and I've never spent any time in
bars and yet I've spent an inordinate
amount of time in this bar and it's
really shaped and changed my opinion
about [__] bars and drinkers in
general as well I used to be pretty
judgy uh now not so much because I found
a bar full of like-minded individuals
where everybody knows my name at least
[Laughter]
uh that was a great [__] question man
excellent [__] job
[Applause]
thank you it was good [__] times man
I got to walk down memory lane and [__]
like that uh next time we do this I'm
sure we'll stream uh between now and
then but we're doing this live again uh
and it may happen here before this
happens but we're doing
when is it um back at smart Castle
August August anybody know the date
25th that's right August 25th we'll be
returning to uh smod Castle to do fat
man beyond Mark's coming out to Jersey
uh tickets at smodcast you're all
invited everybody could come come to
Jersey I got more seats there yeah road
trip literally seats but no liquor
um so yeah show is a lot tougher when
there's no booze trust me
um and then the next night we're doing
you know Mark when we did an episode of
uh
fat man beyond joked about doing uh The
Ides of Mark
um where he did a film festival and we
wound up taking the joke and actually
doing it and putting it up at smodcast
Castle so last time we did fat man
beyond there mark talked about doing
another festival called keep calm and
Curry on a Tim Curry film festival and
so we didn't do a film festival but the
next night August 26th we're doing a
double feature called Keep Calm and
Carry On where we're showing clue and
Then followed by Legend and we'll both
be there hosting and stuff so if you're
on the east coast and you're like [__]
that looks good I wish I could [__]
go there and stuff number one make your
way out here like the mecca of geek
paradises uh here to the scum and
villainy cantina but if you can't do
that and you're on the east coast and
you want to see us do this kind of thing
live coming to smodcast Castle Cinemas
uh August 25th and 26th you can get
tickets for that right now uh I'll be
going back to Jersey this weekend coming
up a week from today we're doing a
screening of Jersey Girl the Snyder cut
longest cut of Jersey girl that has
never been [__] seen and stuff like
that a bunch of stuff going on at smog
Castle Cinemas this summer I'm probably
going to be back East for a few months
because we got some [__] to do back
there uh so if you're looking for me uh
out here probably I won't be here as
much as I will be back there but I get
back here the first week in August and
so you better be sure that we'll be back
here in the bar it'd be nice to keep to
get this going on a regular basis again
because when JC was like you guys
haven't done it since April of 2022 I
was like where the [__] were we where
have we been and the convenience store
took up a lot making clerks cutting
clerks and then touring clerks took up a
lot of time and stuff then I went crazy
and then uh and then I bought the movie
theater so I've been spending a lot of
time back East but uh yeah come August
there'll be a lot more uh fat man beyond
right here at scum and villainy uh in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard that's
another aspect of this place that
like really [__] does it for me I was
a kid who loved the idea of Hollywood
being from New Jersey and one of my
favorite vacations I ever took was when
my father was like you know [__] he's
got three kids but the [__] you know
I was the one that was way into this
[__] and he told my mom like well the
fat one likes Hollywood so let's [__]
let's go to Hollywood and so I came out
here at age nine I've talked about
before going to uh the Chinese Theater
looking at the footprints and [__] like
that and then years later I got to have
my footprints at the Chinese Theater so
being in Hollywood has always been a big
[__] deal to me are we signing these
there are's they're ours okay
what's up Levi how are you man
Tucson okay so we'll do these so
Hollywood has always been you know I
know a lot of like it's very fashionable
on [__]
Twitter for a percentage of the audience
to be like [__] Hollywood
um in a weird political way and [__] but
Hollywood to me as always represented
um something that meant something to me
somewhere I always wanted to go and
always wanted to be it's there's a
reason why both Jay and Silent Bob
movies are about people that want to
[__] go to Hollywood even though they
want to go to stop a [__] thing but
there's a journey to it and and that has
everything to do with like the Muppet
movie when I was a kid going to see the
Muppet movie and it's for me that's
yours my bad
um
and I've always identified with that
story loved it since I saw it when I was
a kid because going to Hollywood was
something I always dreamed about and and
you know I live in Hollywood technically
and I now work in Hollywood and right on
Hollywood Boulevard you know we walk
outside this place and there are stars
on the [__] sidewalk
um there's an open one
Kevin Smith fan club just saying yeah
again we'll make that happen
um one day I I do I mean I'm I'm not a
nakedly ambitious man but I do want to
before I [__] leave this best of all
possible worlds get a [__] star on
Hollywood Boulevard but I'm in no rush
but when it happens he's so [__]
appropriate if it was right outside of
this place but doing the show here in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard like
means something to me I was always happy
when you opened this place for that very
reason I was like Jesus you don't get
more Hollywood than being on Hollywood
Boulevard in [__] Hollywood so or
more expensive yeah [__] talk to them
about rent Jesus Christ
um but it's it's that's a big part of
why I enjoy this so [__] much every
time I come here to do a show not only
is it like filling some [__] you know
desperate need to be loved and [__] but
it's also filling some childhood wish of
like that seems like a wonderful place
place to go and you all give me a
wonderful place to go whenever we do
this show so a thank you from the bottom
of my heart everybody in this room uh
for giving us a reason to [__] come
here and gather time and time again uh
it's taken a [__] year and change to
get back here but here we are man it
meant the world to me to do this here
tonight you all have a good time this
evening kids
we cannot do this show on Hollywood
Boulevard here in Hollywood at this
coming villain in Cantina without the
[__] man who owns and operates his
place give it up for the bar keep
himself Batman JC
and this show would not be what it is
ladies and gentlemen without the very
educated man a very heartfelt man uh one
of my closest friends in the [__]
world who stands next to me to my left
give it up for the one and only Mark
Bernard
and that my friends is fat man beyond
number 400 for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I am Mark Bernard tune in next time same
fat Time same fat channels podcast.com
or YouTube .com Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
everybody
[Applause]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask if anything every
Saga has a 10-year anniversary ladies
and gentlemen and this is what happens
with Jay and Silent Bob get old off
Kevin Smith
foreign